today it's about rule changes and i
guess now we can say it's about rule
change chris because one of the major
proposals that was due to be discussed
and potentially voted on by owners today
has been withdrawn this is the sky judge
proposal there were two of them one of
them would have created a booth umpire
the other one would have created a
senior technology adviser to the referee
they don't want to use the term sky
judge for some reason although i prefer
the phrase
regardless it was the concept that would
have been employed and it's rare to see
the proposal actually withdrawn before
the meeting itself what more typically
happens is
during the meeting
the proposal gets tabled which is the
fancy way of saying it's basically dead
and
it's unlikely that it's ever going to
come back
having it withdrawn ahead of time to me
feels like
the teams that made this proposal and
this is a couple of proposals that came
from the chargers and ravens i believe
it wasn't from the competition committee
i think they're trying to give the nfl a
little cover here knowing in advance
that there was no way this thing was
going to make it through and they didn't
want to put the nfl in a tough spot
because i think the more they talk about
it and the more that we talk about it
and the more that fans know about it
the more it seems like it's going to
happen if it doesn't happen they're
inviting a pr backlash where people say
why in the hell aren't you doing it
yeah that i i think you're right mike i
do you know i i think when um you know
the nfl's not prepared for this that's
what i think the bottom line is right
now you know i think we heard some of
the comments from troy vincent earlier
in the week just talking about enough
capable individuals being in the in the
booth to be that sky judge whatever it
is so i i i think last year with the
past interference calls that scarred the
nfl a little bit because of the
unintended consequences that we've been
talking about and everybody else has
been talking about as well to where
yes i think a lot of people think this
makes sense this kind of takes the
discussion off the table right now and
doesn't shine a bright light on it
because you know i don't think the nfl
is prepared and i don't mean like not
prepared i just don't think they've
thought it out well enough i don't think
it's uh far enough down the road to
where they've started to think of think
about the training and things that need
to be done for that position the sky
judge and how that'll work so hopefully
that'll be something that they'll
continue to talk about and toy with and
have a better or more concrete plan
after next year to where then it can
come back to the table and then we can
have a conversation about it again and
maybe it happens that way but i i think
that's my read i'm similar to you there
it is a combination of factors i believe
and we talked earlier in the week about
this pipeline concern the pipeline gets
full pretty quickly if you are paying an
appropriate wage to the people who are
serving as this guy judges you can if
you want to and if you're willing to and
and if you value the position that was a
phrase that dean blandino used on the
pftpn podcast a couple of years ago
talking about the job he held at the nfl
that executive vp or senior vp of
officiating
they don't value that job meaning there
is a better
living to be earned by people with those
skills
in leaving the nfl going to fox going to
nbc espn cbs wherever and becoming their
officiating expert their rules analyst
if the nfl really wanted to bring back
17 former officials to staff this guy
judge position you can do it if you're
willing to write the checks that's part
of it but i talked to somebody yesterday
before the proposals were withdrawn and
i was told look there's a concern
that we're going to walk right in that
these are this is my characterization
this isn't a direct quote but the
concern is they're going to walk right
into the same buzz saw they walked into
last year and by by troy vincent being
so candid with peter king in this week's
football morning in america about how
badly they screwed up replay review for
pass interference they don't want to
just jump onto the next train without
fully understanding where the train's
going and and it's it's almost like last
year's failure
was so spectacular they're gun shy now
and they they're they're more willing to
go back to what the rules were for the
rams saints debacle in the nfc
championship game that sparked all of
this they're willing to re-embrace that
for a year in lieu of doing something
else because in their mind something
else
may be worse than what they had back in
2018
well yeah i i mean yes first off i i do
think they kind of rushed to
you know make something happen or make
amends for the nfc championship game
blunder i understand that but i think
like i i'm i'm all in favor of them
tabling this sky judge discussion right
now for those same reasons though mike i
mean that year you know after the ram
saints debacle we were in arizona a few
months after that right for the owners
meetings and we were going we didn't
hear a lot of talk about them you know
the past interference review what's
going to happen is it going to come up
you know and it was that week where all
of a sudden it sounded like a few
coaches and people on the competition
committee really started to talk about
it and go like hey wait we got to get
into this a little bit so they were
unprepared that year and it led to last
year being all over the place with that
rule and i think they learned their
lesson at least from from that
standpoint that they shouldn't do that
again and then with the sky judge and
all that yeah i think they want to get
it right i mean this is not going to be
an easy procedure it's not and getting
the qualified people i think is
important and making sure that you know
the process is done the right way and
when that sky judge is allowed to jump
in and when he's not and all of those
type of things they all got to get
figured out if we just want to smooth uh
a smooth entertainment value type thing
on tv to where we can enjoy football and
not have any questions and not sit there
and go holy cow can we get this going
this is the fifth stoppage of you know
play we've had over here because the sky
judge sees something and he's over
critical or whatever it is so
i just think right now just like the
past interference thing mike i mean i
feel like the sky judge this
conversation came out of nowhere i feel
like we we heard little blurbs of it and
then all of a sudden last week it was
like hey we're thinking about the sky
judge so i don't think anybody in the
nfl was really ready for it and i don't
think there's been enough deep
discussion between owners gms and
coaches especially to really figure it
out and hash it out and make it make it
be done the right way
well i know they've had other challenges
this year with the pandemic in the
effort to continue with life as normal
or as close to normal as it can be but
look it's on them to find a way to work
through the issues it's on them to
recognize yesterday the importance of
coming up with mechanisms to get calls
right and and here's my concern the nfl
is extremely conservative and i don't
mean that politically i mean they don't
want to change they want to continue
things the way they are they are
reactive not proactive and now they're
in a weird spot where
all of this is a reaction to ram saints
and a reaction to their mistake from
last year but now they are kind of
hunkering down afraid of making another
mistake willing to go back to 2018
procedures and if they can kick the can
successfully this year my concern is
without some incident that sparks the
outcry that forces them to consider
doing something
2020 becomes 2021 becomes 2022 and
nothing changes and we're back to where
some argued we should have been in the
first place and this was your case it's
a one in a hundred year thing let's not
overreact to it let's go back to the way
things were and we'll deal with it if it
happens again and it won't happen again
for a long time but let me say this
i had a conversation yesterday with
someone about my concern that as
legalized gambling proliferates
postpander that's right states are
trying to balance their budgets and
create tax revenue and more and more
people are betting their hard-earned
money on football they have to be
spending the time and the money and the
effort necessary to create the
impression they're trying to get every
call right and i was told when you say
that you are not 99.9 accurate you are
100.0 percent accurate that is exactly
where this is heading that is exactly
where it is going so hopefully enough
people within that bubble within that
nfl bubble will understand hey
we need to be ahead of this one because
if we continue to take these risks with
doughnut holes that allow us to be
exposed as incompetent see
hey sometimes people say oh they're just
incompetent but when you have millions
of dollars being wagered on these games
at some point somebody's going to say is
it really incompetence or is there
something else going on is there
something deliberate happening is the
fix in is somebody on the take is
somebody betting
and then you have politicians and
prosecutors and other people
bothering you right they are probing
around investigating they're trying to
change the way you do business you got
to get ahead of that and handle it
yourself so you don't have to worry
about somebody else swooping in saying
you got a mess here and we're going to
clean it up for you that's what they
need to avoid chris well yeah a hundred
percent that'll be an absolute disaster
and with sky judge you know that
practice makes perfect they they gotta
you know work out the wrinkles a little
bit have have you know a sky do it in
pre-season football start to feel it out
how it works that way you know again i
don't think it's something that we
should just dive into we learned our
lesson last year last year was annoying
our hundreds of 100 seasons yeah go
ahead how do you how do you staff the
position and only use it for the
preseason that's the problem if they
ever do it they need to do it for a one
year experiment and they need to commit
to it the whole year you can't just say
we're going to have 17 people that we
throw into this booth just to see how it
goes you have to have people who are
committed to it you can say oh bob oh
you know what we decided not to do it
for the regular season thanks for the
four weeks of work now go find something
else to do that's the problem with this
if you're talking about 17 people who
need to be hired it can't just be a
pre-season experiment well no but i'm
just talking about experiment just at
least start there this year to where we
can get and work some of the kinks out
and start to realize those unintended
consequences then yes if we go wow all
right we like this and the nfl and the
people that make these decisions start
to realize okay we think we can do this
in a smooth way it's not too intrusive
the sky job just involved only when he
needs to and all those type of things
then you start to source out and go okay
we need 17 you know or we need a bunch
of other guys to fill this position
whatever whatever that is now here's the
question i want to ask you
like
let's just say ram saints debacle that
type of play happens in week four this
year
do you think
al riverand's gonna just buzz down this
time like any time we haven't
no you don't think so it's not going to
do it not going to do it not going to do
it you know why he's not going to do it
why
i i believe
that he thought about doing it the last
time and he decided the rules prevent it
from happening i can't do it until the
rules are changed he's not going to
break those rules deliberately you know
sometimes maybe accidentally or
spontaneously somebody blurts something
out into that pipeline and the the
pipeline gets used in a way that maybe
it shouldn't and we've had moments where
we're watching games and we say huh new
york is talking to them when maybe they
shouldn't be right i believe i believe
based on everything i've been told
that that
in the moment consideration was given to
doing it and a decision was made not to
do it now now could there be in a big
game could there be somebody sitting
next to al river on who overrides him
and says you get on that line and you do
this you know it's that you have to know
when to do it it can't be yeah
it has to be
know it when you see it egregious type
of a play so i look to me
if you're going to stick with the
pre-2019 procedures you need to be
willing to break protocol and tell the
referee to drop a flag when the seven
people on the field have missed it and
it truly is egregious but i don't think
that al riveron is comfortable
discerning when to do it and when not to
do it but agree for a big game
standalone game if he's got somebody
sitting next to him who is higher than
him on the pecking order and says
do it then he'll do it and he can say
hey i'm just doing what i was told so i
don't rule that out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports